[Musique]
avec le massif du Mont Blanc à l'horizon
et Genève et l'immense lac Léman à
quelques kilomètres seulement la ville
d'Annemasse où habite 38 000 personnes
offrent un décor et a priori un
quotidien bien différent de celui des
cités de la banlieue de Paris et
pourtant
[Musique]
pendant 3 nuits la fin de semaine
dernière des dizaines de jeunes y ont
volé saccagé brûlés commercez bien
public un petit morceau madame en ce
jour de marché dans le quartier
populaire de Perrier où est né la
révolte les résidences se remettent
encore des événements difficiles
d'oublier quand les traces sont juste à
côté là ça a commencé par une intrusion
ici au rez-de-chaussée on croise
Françoise qui nous parle de cette maison
Nelson Mandela qui hébergeait des
services communautaires elles servaient
aussi deux lieux de rencontres pour les
jeunes le samedi matin quand on est venu
voir l'état je peux vous dire que tout
le monde était en larmes les employés
les bénévoles on était tous vraiment
anéantis tout ce travail qu'on fait
depuis des années on aurait dit que tous
s'écroulait ou que ça avait servi à rien
depuis 9 ans Françoise fait partie du
comité citoyen dont le mandat est
d'offrir une meilleure qualité de vie
dans le quartier Périer ou vivent 4000
personnes comptent 82% de logements
sociaux et plus du tiers des résidents
vivent dans la pauvreté c'est un
quartier multi-ethnique vibrant et bien
entretenu mais aussi un haut lieu du
trafic de drogue il y a une tranche
d'âge qu'on ne connaît pas après 15 ans
25 ans cela on les connaît pas et du
coup
quand ils font un truc de violence comme
ça on est complètement démuni parce que
on voit pas la raison
j'habite ici c'est la première fois je
vois ça comme tout le monde ici B chez
Binta savent bien que derrière la case
se cache souvent des jeunes en détresse
on allait simple de loisirs on a on a
refait Annemasse on a tout fait mais je
pensais à trop de chômage aussi il y a
beaucoup de chômage et le chômage ne
vient pas seulement danemar c'est toute
la France plus de douche pour cent des
15 à 29 ans en France ne sont ni en
emploi ni en formation
parce que moi même je le vis même les
flics il y a des problèmes qu'il a
appelé ou tu vas aller faire une plainte
Italie il y a trop de immigrés ils sont
abandonnés à côté c'est ça qui amène la
merde
renforcée par la mort du jeune Naël
cette opinion que la police est raciste
revient souvent à Annemasse toujours le
même type de personnes contrôlées et des
fois malheureusement subir des coups
qu'elle est pas forcément lieu d'avoir
donc du coup c'est en fait ça a été un
ras-le-bol des jeunes du quartier Émilie
élève 3 ans dans Périer avec d'autres
parents elle a patrouillé dans le
quartier lors des nuits d'émeutes pour
limiter les dégâts on a tourné toute la
nuit on a fait une nuit blanche on en a
ramené en fait on a commencé le vendredi
on a ramené chez eux en laissant par les
oreilles on les a ramenés chez leurs
parents comme de nombreux résidents ici
elle se sent abandonnée par les élus lui
il faut bien le dire aussi c'est la non
maîtrise d'un certain nombre de jeunes
quoi y compris des jeunes de 13 14 ans
devant son hôtel de ville à 2 km du
marché le maire d'Annemasse rappelle
qu'il investit plus d'une centaine de
millions d'euros dans le quartier Périer
la rénovation urbaine c'est plutôt une
réussite ce qu'on a du mal à traiter
c'est le contenu c'est les gens qui sont
dedans et ce qui nous manque à nous et
le Conseil des moyens de fonctionnement
des moyens pour avoir plus d'éducateurs
dans la rue pour avoir plus de
travailleurs sociaux il faut mieux
combattre le trafic de drogue
ajoute-t-il et améliorer les liens entre
la police et la communauté c'est
l'élément qu'il faut retravailler le le
contenu de la police la formation des
policiers la police de proximité elle
avait cette capacité à créer des liens
autres que le lien répressif c'est
Sarkozy à sabrer là-dessus je crois que
c'est une faute une faute politique
qu'on paye aujourd'hui le choc passé
Françoise ne tarit pas d'éloges pour son
quartier des gens qui font plein de
choses sur ce quartier c'est très vivant
malgré les nombreuses tensions en France
elle demeure positive on a connu pire
moi j'ai vécu à Lyon c'était affreux on
se battait avec les flics dans les
années 70-80 c'était horrible moi je
suis optimiste je pense que les gens
sont résilients on va y arriver
Émilie pense aussi que son quartier va
se relever mais elle est plus pessimiste
honnêtement je commence à m'inquiéter
pour mon propre pays
parce que en fait le gouvernement
n'écoute pas son peuple
la France a de grands défis devant elle
ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada
Annemasse